why isn't anybody else just made Bitcoin
huh why isn't anybody else just made
another version of Bitcoin well there's
a lot of people who tried and there's
people who say that they created bitcoin
no no not like that I guess what I'm
saying is like just create a limited
number of them no they did and what it
just didn't know the same way no there
were it's um when you think of like Tech
Innovation uh the true Innovation is
where all the value accrues right so
it's like uh a lot of times people use
the the terminology zero to one like
it's the actual Innovation is where the
value is and so that's what Bitcoin did
and you have to remember too like now if
somebody launched a coin there's like
every degenerate in the world it's like
looking around on the internet like who
got the coins what are the coins where's
the new coin right so you're attracting
people who are like more uh mercenaries
than missionaries in the early days of
Bitcoin at first there was no price
there was no exchange there was no
anything like people who wanted it were
like they believed in the technology and
they got it they mined it and the
missionaries right a lot of drugs on the
internet with it yeah
that was the game my sister bought a
bought mushrooms for like five Bitcoin
back in 2011. get the [ __ ] yeah
take a truth the truth
recently she was like yeah I bought it
like 100 Grand on Silk Road yeah it
wasn't that many Bitcoin but yeah it was
like it was like half a Bitcoin or full
Bitcoin there's that story about the guy
buying a slice of pizza or something
like that for 10 Bitcoin yeah no no no
10 000 Bitcoins she's been on two pizzas
yeah yeah it's like hundreds of millions
of dollars today
hahaha
we have zero compassion
no it is true people I feel like it's
the first is the first transaction in
history where somebody like used it to
buy something
he like went online he was like yo if I
send someone Bitcoin like will you get
me a pizza and I think if I remember
correctly they like called The Dominoes
or you know whatever pizza place in his
hometown and was like will you bring
this dude to Pizza I'll pay for it and
then they send them the 10 000 Bitcoin
wow crazy
does that dude still have the Bitcoin is
he still a horse I'm sure there's a lot
of Bitcoin yeah I'm not sure what
happened the Bitcoin they've asked the
guy who spent the 10 000 Bitcoin he's
like no I don't regret it at all because
he's like Bitcoin probably wouldn't have
become what it became unless we started
to use it which I think is what you have
to tell yourself
the guy that's not in the Beatles
anymore is like the best thing that ever
happens I love my life love my fat kid
my fat wife Bitcoins down yeah are you
buying more uh I have been buying more
uh I I'm always gonna buy more and it's
just like nothing about Bitcoin has
changed that didn't sound as confident
[Laughter]
bro I'm like uh
I'm in the 11th the round of a 12 round
fight I've been getting punched all year
right and I'm like yo man I'm still here
all right let's go whatever but if you
if you think about Bitcoin all I keep
looking at is like the underlying
fundamentals are exactly the same
um and oh there's a lot of people who
are like oh what does that mean or
whatever it's just like
a company who is doing it the same or
more in whether it was revenue or sales
or whatever metric you want to look at
but the stock price went down some
people be like yo stock price down I'm
out okay that's fine but the people who
would look at the actual company and say
hey I like this it's doing the things I
wanted to do I just think that it's a
cheaper price for the same company
they'll buy so like that's where the
market ends up like that's where people
Express their view there's a lot of
people buying because the there's two
stats that just blow my mind
the amount of Bitcoin in the last 12
months that hasn't moved is almost 70
percent
70 of the Bitcoin people are holding
even though the price went down 75
people believe it's going back up
they're not [ __ ] selling right
they're not moving it so like that's an
interesting stat and then the second one
is uh on chain like on the blockchain
you can see uh the wallet addresses with
uh 0.1 or 0.01 Bitcoin so think a couple
hundred dollars uh to a couple thousand
dollars those the number of those
wallets keep hitting all-time highs
meaning that it's not Wall Street guys
buying it's like the small little people
are saying hey I buy 20 bucks every week
now I've got two three 500 worth of
bitcoin right in this wallet and so like
I think that those are signals that uh
there is some portion of the uh kind of
holder base or the bitcoiners that just
they're still buying it's just not you
know hundreds of millions of dollars
like we saw with the Wall Street guys
were coming in